spoiler alert you have no idea what's
coming
mr. wit broke the rules
I trust you understand the repercussions
if he survives one of my favorite
moments in this film is the knife fight
I think it's just one of the most badass
knife fights that we've ever seen on
film can you break it down a little bit
for me in and how long did it take to
shoot and how complex really was it
because it looked crazy right yes the
knife fight the knife fight was I think
we shot two nights maybe three well the
other sequence I'd say over the course
of two three days nights yeah it was
involves multiple fighters it's there's
some judo in it and there's some gun
fighting gun food there's a lot of knife
work
I guess what what kind of made it easier
and safer was that we were throwing in
certain sections imaginary knives so we
didn't have to literally throw cuz even
if you throw a rubber knife or you know
it's still gonna hurt but there was a
certain sections that I did I had that
accident I had the throw and a couple of
times I had it but I wasn't supposed to
let it go but I did but I got good aim
so we just went past so of course in
various days getting the timing I would
say the timing you know John wit kills a
character with a book movie spoiler if
you were a real-life assassin what would
be the most mundane household item that
you would use I don't know I mean for
John wick it's all weapons of
opportunity like his life everything in
the world is a weapon of opportunity I
don't know what would be I mean it's
hopefully you're not in that situation
we stay in the pretend worlds so I don't
know so John wick what would he what
would what would be fun for some reason
I mean it's yeah I don't know egg beater
something igby butter butter yeah like
how would you kill someone with
something soft you know would you
suffocate them like what would John wick
do hope yours I can see we picked up my
way I don't know do you have a favorite
fight scene in this movie I love the
knife fight there's a certain section
called it's section 2 of the the Glass
House section and I thought the the
horseback the horse the the brief horse
section I think is really special you
know and how many more is it unique it
is very unique how many more of these do
you think you got in you I mean I
imagine it takes a toll it does but
that's that's gift you know if it wasn't
if there wasn't any toll and you know
you're not traveling right you're paying
a toll so you can get somewhere man
it's really up to the audience and I
mean I think the story in the world you
know kid could be complete can be
revealed and you know there's stories to
tell there but III don't know physically
I don't know do you personally have a
direction where you'd like to see John
go from here um I don't
first things first hopefully people
enjoy the film and we get that up you
shouldn't be here nice suit good to see
you too I need your help
after this we are less than even I'd
love for you guys to break down a little
bit of the sequence where Hallie and
John are fighting and the dogs are in it
how long did it take to shoot that how
complex was it and and for Hallie what
was the most challenging part of
shooting when you do an action moves
especially for a budget and for the time
constraints we have there's a certain
degree you plan you try to prepare for
the worst that's what we got for all our
second year second year experience from
the conception the dogs are trained for
nearly eight months to be reactive
around humans and to have the cameraman
and then gunfire out how he probably
trained anywhere from five and a half to
six months five homes solid with the
dogs five days a week to find the right
locate we lost locations things happen
weather changes the dogs needed to be
shot at night quiet in locations that we
can control so we did have a lot about
like New York City was not an option so
we found a small town and northern
Morocco to do it and then we had a
location loss location and we had
another location but there's like 300
cats and dogs don't like cats as you
guys or they love them too much so we
had to control that it's just a lot of
went into it so by the time we got done
the main riad or the main sequence that
you see with Hallie keen on the dogs
which three nights plus an additional
half day for the vehicle scene at the
end when they jump in and out of the
cars so if you really look at it and
you're looking at almost eight months of
time collectively almost a year and a
half between Hallie and the dogs to get
done in three days which is wild for a
year and a half of training to do it in
three days but that also speaks to the
training I mean if you have some of this
as well
you know we train for six weeks but it
took us six months to shoot that's not
an efficient return the fact that we
could get so much action and such I
think elaborate footage done in such a
short period of time speaks to the the
efficiency and the need for for the
training with the type of training we
did the intense training we did and
talked about that intense training I
mean what was the most challenging part
of it was it the gunplay was that the
dogs interacting with the dogs you know
I think for me it was all of it it was
meshing you know all of it there were
times when I had to do sort of my my
fighting I had to also have my guns that
I had to command my dogs like all at one
time that was pretty challenging to keep
that all together in my mind and that
the challenging the most kanji part was
the way Chad works is that you know I
really never learned choreo ever I just
learned the moves and I learned I
trained and but nobody ever taught me
the choreography I'm like what am I
gonna learn the choreography finally I
realized oh the way Chad works his you
show up on the day and he sees the the
set and he sees the situation we're
working with because as he said he lost
sets got set and then he and his stunt
guys come up with the scene and then ten
minutes later we have to shoot it so
that was the most challenging part I
mean that was fear of God set in on me
in those days when I hoped that I would
get it and I wouldn't let him down and
then all that training would come back
to me thank god it did I did into the
John Waite methodology if you were
real-life assassins and you what would
be the household item that you would
choose as your weapon of choice
the stiletto heels is stilettos do some
damage with the shoe what about you
check oh just my my sparkling
personality and sharp wit there or a
steak knife you either you've got a
nasty surprise coming I've been looking
forward to meeting you
long time that's a mark if you could
break down that final fight scene a
little bit for us how long did it take
to shoot did you get hurt with it how
crazy was it fighting Keanu with
something it was a joy a blast and
inspiration because you know as you
probably know shad our director is a
wonderful talented martial artist
himself so you know he knew exactly what
we were doing and Keanu has been
training for years and he's super tough
and really strong so you know they kind
of set the bar it was almost easy for me
because they set it up here and I just
had to do my best to hang on tight you
know challenging that we were shooting
at nights you know at nights and to
sustain that type of focus and energy
takes a lot out of you because you make
a mistake and you really do get hurt you
know which maybe wouldn't have been so
bad since we're playing hurt anyway but
we did also that final sequence you shot
for a month right yes we shot that final
sequence of over four weeks because we
do other scenes and then come back to
that one you know so that was very
challenging just to come back and and
and pick it right back up where we left
off you know but it was a joy aja
you get the chance to be in scenes with
some real scenery chewers in this film
Laurence Fishburne Keanu Reeves ian
mcshane I mean what was it like with
those guys and do you have a favorite
moment with either of them or any of
them oh gosh I mean you know playing
opposite piano Laurence mark you know
anjelica huston you know these are
people who I like to say it's like
playing tennis with someone who makes
you better for just having played with
them you know and so that was a great
honor and really exciting and it's a
credit to all of those people yourself
included that everyone in the ensemble
is incredibly gracious incredibly humble
and so what could have been a very
intimidating experience was just fun you
know in this film John wick kills a
character with a book if you were
real-life assassins what would be the
most mundane household item you would
use as your weapon of choice the first
thing that came to mind is a spatula
that's what I was thinking yes well then
what is it about this bachelor that
comes to mind immediately its multi-use
tool yeah you know you could flip our
pancakes you can spank you could yeah
you know yeah that's not music
yeah so this spatula I should have said
at the same time with you yeah do you
have a favorite fight from the movie is
it the fight that you're in or is there
another fight from the movie that you
guys weigh you know it's true that all
of the fights are incredibly stunning
and there is a particular fight sequence
that takes place underwater that you
know at minimum it's 30 seconds long at
most it might even be a minute and it's
happening in real time and it's really
Keanu dude I mean it's just for me it
was like it definitely stands out the
final fight sequence and then the horse
I mean come on I'm not gonna see the
movie until the premiere so I don't know
yet Society let's all go with your fight
yeah yeah thank you do you expect you to
meet the daughter's fourteen million
dollar bounty on his head
the city wants a piece of it I say the
other about even so gentlemen I talk a
little bit about your characters because
you get to do more in this film that
we've seen previously Lance I'll start
with you because your character gets it
on the action someone or so in this film
how was that for you that did it require
extra training so first of all it was a
lot of fun and it did require extra
training um it's many many years of play
cops it's actually before I started
training for this film I'd only shot a
real gun twice on a right shooting range
and so I had to do a lot of gun training
and just in terms of the action it was
uh I had to do more gun training than
you know I because I didn't have all the
kind of grappling jujitsu training work
that Hallion a candidate but it was it
was just great it was fun and here what
about your character we learn more about
him in this film where do you see him
sort of going from here and how do you
he's pissed off with a high table John's
his favorite assassin and you don't know
their relationship I mean what is
they've known each other long time like
these characters I mean I'm you know
we're lunch and I talk about we don't
talk about our backstories to each other
but we both have them you know I believe
that we've known each other like thirty
years where we met is doesn't matter but
it's like they're very very tight and
they run this hotel it's their hotel and
once he's threatened by the high table
said oh you can't do it we'll say but
then screw you you know I'll take the
side of John like Laura Lawrence gives
him a weapon I give him an hour from
episode 2 and you're gonna do that for
us you're gonna try and you know no no
no no no and I'm I think the line in the
movie they'll bring the house down this
you know what is this we are the high
table which I think Lords go down New
York you know him you know John wick in
this film kills a character by using a
book if you were real-life assassins
what would be the most mundane household
item that you would use as your weapon
of choice pencil pencil in yeah yeah
cooking spoon
a cooking spoon that's good scoop I'm
not gonna mean cook it's gonna a wooden
spoon a wooden spoon you could he
damaged with over this pool I had to
figure some milk yeah in the throat do
you have a favorite fight from the movie
they cut my fight scene it's curious you
had a fight scene no of course not but I
will demand what if they do know what no
I mean you can't have it
I mean I'm just glad to see that it was
it that Lance got to do some of them
because then it shows that there's a
there is you know that's why we run the
hotel but you have to see and that's
very smart of the you know the producers
in Gion you and Chad to let my character
come out and show it's very important
and to know our relationship he's my
backup you know what I mean together a
long time
and I actually do have and it's it's in
Morocco when Kelly loses it with the
dogs and in the future of this franchise
I mean how how are you guys signed on
for like ten of these or like what's no
one else signed on for any yeah which is
not which you makes it a nice surprise
when they come up with something yeah if
they do and if you didn't hear this is
my ring no I know but it's great I mean
also I think the driving thing behind it
is you know Kiana's performance because
you know he has this wonderful
melancholic relentless attractive and
don't pup with him yes that you know
unch add directing all three of them
than them having their history and now
we have our history so I'd say it's a
real pleasure to come back and they
lunch and you sort of take part in the
storyline to present you finally get to
have season with this guy yeah well we
hopefully more of those scenes in yeah
oh yeah absolutely
[Music]
you